now we escape to mexico
oh man i'm jealous rocky she stopped by
a new pop-up bar experience that will
turn your walk down the strip into a
fiesta
welcome to the villa one tequila garden
it's a beautiful island escape right
here on the strip so cindy tell us about
the two very special owners of this
garden
so we have nick jonas and john barbados
collabing for the villa one tequila this
is their first pop-up shop wow right
here in las vegas and where is it
located exactly tell people how they can
how they can find you so we're located
right here on the harmon retail corner i
usually recommend parking at the tex-mex
and just walking across the bridge for
easy travel that's perfect and you you
guys do make it really easy for us
because as you can see you just walk up
and order your drink yeah it's just an
authentic mexican experience right here
on the shrimps i love it and you design
part of the menu so what kind of drinks
are we having at the villa one tequila
garden so we have the daiquiris we have
that can come in um yardsticks
pineapples
yes super refreshing for the hot heat
here in vegas exactly and then we have
the cannaritos that is um
straight from mexico like the whole
experience the fresh juices and the
zesty lime rock salt
okay so this is an authentic experience
right here so let's get into it the
canterito how do we make this kind of
drink
so we're gonna start by squeezing
lemon
oh my gosh we're gonna sweet fresh juice
okay
some lime how long does it take to make
these cause i'm sure you have this last
you about what a day or no hours so fast
so yeah like literally a few hours okay
we're gonna do some oranges beautiful
yeah people really love like watching it
being made it's so fresh and you know
just really refreshing
what have people been saying as they
come up and discover you guys well
they're just like you know they haven't
experienced anything like this you know
so people coming from here from all
around the world yeah this is not what
they expect so this is a great location
for it
i agree
and we have what are the drinks that
really the juices that make this
authentic so we have fresh squeezed
orange juice
bad to wear white t-shirts trying to
make it
well the white shirts keep you nice and
cool and the hot heat
is going to stir it a little bit
and then of course the main ingredient
is the tequila so what makes the villa
one tequila by nick jonas of the jonas
brothers fashion guru john barbados what
makes it super special
um it's just
overall i like your technique
it's um it's sweeter than most tequila
so it's easy for sipping okay okay
that's good and then we're just going to
top it off with grapefruit juice which
brings it all together
yes
yes
exactly okay and last but not least look
at this you guys oh my gosh
we're going to put it in the very
special authentic cups that you can
actually take with you as you walk the
strip yes our souvenirs
oh my gosh and these are specially
imported so they're handmade handcrafted
super tasty and of course the garnish
right yes
let's top it all off
gotta
and cheers to villa one tequila garden
now what's the future of this place
though i hear you guys are growing so we
are growing this is our first location
um we're going we're expanding to san
diego la new york miami and we're also
expanding right here in vegas of course
so we got to follow you guys at villa
one tequila gardens yes
okay well cheers to you cheers sydney
you guys come down this is delicious